you guys might want to come around a bit
closer so that you can see
um
now in keeping with so probably likely
when it's time you might want actually
maybe you can stand over here for a
second because that'll get from the
front anyway so in keeping with the
whole idea of taking a simple game uh
like tic-tac-toe and just putting a
little twist which you know sort of
blows open the morning blows open the
game and makes it far more complicated
and far more interesting okay um i'm
gonna teach you game i just like
literally just two days ago i think
discovered
and it takes a very simple game which
which you guys should all know which if
you don't know i'll teach you now and
adds adds just one twist and it makes it
really painful now the game is is called
the the simple game is thumb war now you
know how to play them all so [ __ ] and i
will demonstrate well
the way a thumb war works normally okay
is how do you how do you start you go
one two three four i declare five more
wait
um oh then we have to wrestle and then
someone has to pin down there so for
example poc would win now you know for
instance that's fine but then and there
are all kinds of other strategies for
instance like this you really shouldn't
do this but i had a friend who yeah he
used to be like one two three four i'd
occur a thumb war ninja kick haha
or or after you're like you know i know
that i'm not gonna do that give me that
one two three four i declare a thumb war
dynamite so anyway
just play it normally that's the way it
goes and then you know it's it's that's
that's it basically there's only one
accommodation okay so
that's a regular thumbnail okay now
what i'm going to teach you is called um
massively multiplayer thumb war okay not
much massively multiplayer online rpg
but
um but massively multiplayer so what
we're going to do first is we need to
bring some more players in so at the
moment there's just two of us okay so um
now this is this is where you'll need to
come around um so so on this hand still
if you can you should be able to put in
more than one one set of hands so for
instance if you come in there
all right so this is this is four you
can do more than that but it starts to
get a bit like i can't reach everyone
else in the um
in the circle
now normally when it's just two players
right there's a little bit of a standoff
and kind of like oh you sort of wait and
you're like go back and forth
here you know there's no reward for
holding back it's just the first person
to pin anyone will win okay so for
instance if i if i pin pop now and
someone else pins me
i've still won because i've i've pinned
the first person so it's a game of speed
unless i get out and then
no no i picked well i've really pinned
you that you can't get out right like
it's got to be a real pin yeah anyway
okay so that's that's the first um
element of massively multiple player
some more that you have more than two
thumbs in there but the other thing is
uh everyone at the moment at least in
this arrangement has a free hand right
so what you need to do is bring your
bring your other hand in okay so here we
go
all right and then and then you play
again so you do the same thing
you start off the same way you're ready
so i think i lost twice elaine got me on
this hand and why did you both target me
so so there's this two victories and you
know
yeah i don't know
so that's why
with the four of us that's the way we
would play but there's more than four of
us here okay so instead of we'd have you
know four hands in here so off you go
and then you're probably gonna have
other people who you can reach with your
other free hand okay so everyone in this
room
it's kind of like uh to make your ipt
relevant it's kind of like a partial
mesh i guess
so
everyone needs to be
does that make sense yeah i don't think
it'll work